오늘 근데 장이 1번 빠지진 않았습니까?
오늘 8000 터치하려다가
저 그 범인을 찾았습니다.
제가 사실 어제 못 참고
반도체 ETF에 들어갔다고 합니다.
제가 도저히 SK 하이닉스 살 수가 없어가지고
돈이 없어서 ETF를 가거나
근데 그 10명 너무 잘 아는데
그게 왜 하필 어제였죠?
왜 하필
못 잡을 거예요.
차렷!
니니쌤께 경례!
안녕하십니까?
반갑습니다.
죽지도 않고 또 왔다.
근데 이 강의 폐강되는 거 아니었어요?
지금 여기 현강 듣고 싶다고 줄 서신 분들이
위포로 꽤 많아요.
여러분들이 이거 돈 내고 사실 들으셔야 되는 건데
공짜로 듣게 해주는 거에 대해서
감사하게 생각하셔야 됩니다.
근데 제가 저번에 들었을 때는
사실 신고를 하려고 했었는데
코스피가 7000을 돌파한 시점에서
저 진짜 오늘 강의만을 기다렸습니다.
제가 12000을 간다고 했나 안 했나
했습니다!
그렇지!
아 근데 저는 사실 그 12000이
뭐 그냥 무지성으로 나온 거 같아요?
어? 무지성 아니었어요?
아 진짜
지성이 있는데 그런 소리를
오선님이 국장 얘기할 때마다
니니님한테 물어봐요.
머니코미스트 가서 물어봐라.
내 생각엔 오선님도 니니 리딩 따라오는 거 같아요.
밤에는 미장하시고
낮에는 국장 공부할 시간 없으니까
그냥 니니가 집어주는 것만 사시는 거 같아요.
니니쌤 강의를 듣다 보니까
생각나는 책 이름이 하나 있습니다.
거인의 어깨에 올라타라.
거인의 어깨에 올라타야 됩니다, 저희.
어깨 하다가 살짝 옷을 봤는데
저 명품 브랜드 아닌가요?
아 이거 살짝 티가 났나요?
가린다고 가렸는데.
아 뭐야?
부의 향기는 좀 가려지지가 않나 봐요.
사실 뭐냐면
여러분 돈 벌었다고 좀 꺼드럭대면서
뭐 명품관 가고 아울렛 지금 기웃거리시는 분들 좀 있을 텐데
그러면 안 됩니다.
짭인가요?
짭은 아니고
이건 제 동생이
2월 상품?
저에게 자기 안 입는다고 준 거예요.
남동생 아닙니까?
맞습니다.
남동생이 지금
얼추 옷피스 다 했어요.
아 오늘 근데 장이 한 번 빠지진 않았습니까?
아 오늘 8000...
한 번 터치하려다가 빠졌죠.
저 그 범인을 찾았습니다.
제가 사실 어제 못 참고
반도체 ETF에 들어갔다고 합니다.
제가 도저히 SK하이닉스 살 수가 없어서
돈이 없어서 ETF를 샀구나.
근데 그 심정 너무 잘 아는데
그게 왜 하필 어제였죠?
왜 하필 고점이 있어요?
반도체 지금 하이닉스가 200만 원 가고 있는 이 와중에
어제 샀다는 거예요.
아 근데 왜 제가 사면 떨어지죠?
아니 근데 요즘은 닌이가 픽하면
일단은 뭔가 있나 보다는 그런
저도 제가 무서워요.
나 어디까지 보고 있는 거야?
나 어디까지 보고 있는 거지?
근데 죄송한데 오늘 그 옷 입고 그렇게 얘기하시니까
자산설계사 같다.
지금 주식시장은 여러분 잘 아시겠지만
두 부류로 나뉩니다.
포모가 온 사람, 포모가 안 온 사람
저는 일단 포모가 온 거 같습니다.
근데 웃긴 거 먼저 압니까?
제가 그래도 좀 나눠 담는다고
전략 반도체 타이거도 있고 코덱스도 있거든요.
근데 좀 달라요.
두 개를 나눠서 샀거든요.
50% 50%
나눠 산 게 분할 배수가 아니고
타이거랑 코덱스
왜 그걸 나눠서 사는 거겠지?
네?
그 왜요?
구성 종목이 다른데요.
구성 종목이 달라요.
저 궁금한 게 있었습니다.
저는 사실 감으로 하거든요.
상무님이 좀 저한테 소스를 많이 주시는데
상무님이 뭐라고 하면
어? 괜찮아 보인다.
들어가야지 하는데
혹시 어떻게 매매를 해야 될지
이게 주식이라는 거에 대해서
한번 생각을 해봐야 됩니다.
항상 뉴스나 R상무님이나 슈카님이 그러잖아요.
네가 잘한 게 아니고 시장이 잘한 거야.
아니에요.
시장이 아니라 내가 잘한 거야.
근데 맞는 것 같습니다.
돈 좀 벌었다고 꺼들어 때리지 마라?
그럼 지금 안 꺼들어 때리면 언제 꺼들어 때릴까?
그렇지. 공감.
주식도 기세예요.
내가 벌었다고 겸손하면 들어올 돈도 안 들어와요.
그 기세, 흐름, 스멜 이런 게 있거든요.
삼장은 핫산 형님이랑 들어갈 때도
20만 원.
그때도 고점이라는 얘기가 많았잖아요.
맞아. 맞아.
어떤 기준으로
맞아요. 근거가 궁금합니다.
제 인스타를 보면 주말에 주식 공부밖에 안 해요.
재미나이로 최근에 공부를 하고 있습니다.
인스타그램에 공부하는 거 올리면
재미나이로 진짜 검색 기록 같은 거
다 주식 얘기로 엄청 물어보더라고요.
제가 사실
재미나이로
주식 얘기밖에 안 해요.
제 재미나이는 아마 알 거예요.
얘가 주식에 미친년이.
잠시만요. 뭐라고요?
주식에 미친 사람이구나.
제가 한번 띄워봐드리면
제가 어떤 식으로 공부하는지
주식은 준비하면서
엄청 많이 하셨네요.
저는 온리 주식이에요.
주식 얘기밖에 안 해요.
스팸 양송이 카레.
양송이 카레 레시피.
아, 요번에
맛있었나요?
재미나이 레시피 짱.
운동 가기 싫을 때 내송이 기절해.
그 기분 정말 잘 알죠.
국내 최고의 경제 프로그램
주식은 지금을 또
MC를 보고 있지 않습니까?
근데 사실 제가 또 아시다시피
현생이 바쁘잖아요.
하루 종일 있었던 뉴스를
팔로우하기가
시간이 너무 없는 거예요.
그럴 때는
1시간 전에
AI 주식은 뭐가 있을까?
사람들이 관심이 있어야 할
요런 식으로 물어보면은
외신 보도, 장전 브리핑
정리를 해줘요.
아, 그럼 오늘
랜드 얘기를 해볼까?
뭐 요런 식으로 아이디어를 얻을 수가 있어요.
그러면은 제가 꼬리에 꼬리를 물고
아, 그럼 국내에는
랜드 시장이 뭐가 있을까?
근데 프롬프트 너무
따뜻하게 해주시면 안 됩니까?
오늘 그러면 코스피 하락의 이유를 물어볼까요?
어, 이런 식으로
구글 서치를 활용해서
바로 나옵니다.
자, 수급 외국인의 역대급 팔자.
아, 그리고 이런 게 있었네요.
정책이
AI 초과이익 공유제라는 게 있었네요.
아, 저 이거 봤어요.
봤어요?
봤는데 왜 샀을?
아니, 아니.
12시쯤에 나왔어요.
봤는데 왜 샀어?
아, 진짜로?
그리고 제가 또 가장 좋아하는 게
해외 기사 있잖아요.
근데
영어를 잘 못해.
해외 주식 하시는 분들 보면은
어닝콜 이런 거 되게
주의 깊게 보잖아요.
그렇죠.
유약해 주나요?
유약해 주죠.
예를 들면
핀비즈라는 사이트가 있잖아요.
네.
근데 내가 이거 볼 줄 몰라.
그러면 이거를
캡쳐하는구나.
화면을 캡쳐를 해요.
와.
바로 핀비즈 맵이 어떤지.
자, 주요 지수는
신고가 부근의 강보합입니다.
다운은 어쩌고 저쩌고.
시장의 핵심 동력은 AI.
캡쳐만 해서 보여줘도
얘가 그냥 한글로 정리를 싹 해주기 때문에
너무 스마트하죠.
이거 진짜 좋은 거 같습니다.
이거 주식 투자하는 사람들은
이거 재미나게 안 쓸 수가 없어요.
그러니까.
제가 사실 가장 많이 활용하는 게 그거예요.
재무재표 보는 거 너무 어렵잖아요.
어려워요.
근데 예를 들면
땡땡전자 재무재표.
그냥 그걸 분석을 다 해주거든요.
저도 제가 관심 있는 종목
재미나게한테 물어봤었는데
영업이익에 따른 해석도 재미나게가 해주더라고요.
선 반영된 건지
맞아요.
리레이팅이 되고 있는 건지
이런 것들도 다 얘가 얘기를 해 주니까
제가 최근에 인텔 재무재표가 궁금해가지고
그러면 어닝 서프라이즈다.
밸류에이션은 이렇다.
이런 것들을 다 정리를 해줘요.
AMD라는 라이벌이 있다.
어떻게 생각하냐.
뭐가 인텔 주가 모먼템을 올릴까라고 하면
그쪽 알려줘요.
1번, 2번, 3번 이런 이런 이런 시나리오가 있으니까
선택을 네가 해.
괜찮다.
괜찮지.
투자 권유는 안 하더라고요.
그럴 때 되게 좋을 것 같아요.
만약에 뭐가 갈 것 같다고 생각하고
이 시나리오가 어떤지 물어볼 때
그렇죠.
항상 저희가 상무님이나 슈카 님한테
여쭤볼 수는 없으니까
재미나게한테 물어보고
눈치 보이지.
거기에 대한 데이터를 알려달라고 하면 돼요.
얘가 실제로 돈을 벌고 있어?
얘가 매출이 얼마나 돼?
라는 걸 물어보면 바로 알려주니까
답단 거 많거든요.
둘 중에 그냥 하나
근데 미국 주식은 평단 낮아.
낮은 게 좀 있어.
어떻게 다 이게 마이너스야?
이게 웃기지 않아요?
아니 국장에서 마이너스가 어떻게
주식을 꼭 해야겠어.
잘 하고 있어?
그렇게만 물어봐도 돼요?
시간이 좀 걸리죠.
얘가 당황한 것 같아.
그렇지.
너 진짜 똑똑하다.
확실한 테마와 주도주 위주의 선구함.
AI 전략기기 ETF 조합은 매우 전략적입니다.
그렇죠.
그냥 좋은 말 해주는 거 아닙니까?
리스크자도 알려줘요.
높은 섹터.
그러니까 기술주에만 쏠려 있다.
코덱스라 타이거까지.
제이하이 전략기기 ETF 조합은 매우 전략적입니다.
제 거를 올려볼까요?
오케이.
궁금하다.
이거 재밌네.
어떨까?
투자 레벨 자체가.
20대 남성분과는 투자 레벨이 다르고.
맞죠.
리스크도 있죠.
종목의 중복.
모든 계좌에서 삼성전자 하이닉스의 계좌를 중복 보유하고 있습니다.
다 샀구나.
이번에는 실습을 한번 해보도록 하겠습니다.
프롬프트를 활용해서 여러분들이 또 기가 막히게 어떻게 사용하는지
한번 보도록 할게요.
저는 청년도약계좌 6개월째 납입 을 하고 있는데.
6월에 청년 미래 적금이 출시가 되잖아요.
청년이셨어요?
갈아타는 게 좋을지.
그거를 물어봤는데 정부 기여금 비율이랑 월 납입한도를 같이 얘기
하면서 6월 한해서만 갈아타기를 인정해 준다고 합니다.
저희 잡돌이다 하던데.
누군데.
오른쪽은 전데.
앞으로 오실 피디님인가 보다.
오늘 이렇게 재미나이와 함께 우리 투자전략 한번 점검을 해봤는데.
여러분 오늘 공부 많이 됐죠.
많이 됐습니다.
사실 이게 오늘 재미나이 광고였지만 광고뿐만 아니라 제가 평소에도
너무 잘 쓰고 있어요.
실제로 쓰고 있습니다.
우리 사무실 모든 사람들이 재미나이를 쓰고 있기 때문에 사실 저희가 성덕
이 됐어요.
맞아요.
광고 주신 재미나이 너무 감사합니다.
투자는 결국 판단은 본인이 하는 거지만 공부하고 또 흐름 정리하는
데는 너무나 스마트한 조언자 도움이 되는 그런 역할을 하고 있으니까
여러분들도 재미나이를 활용해서 성투하시고.
자 그럼 오늘 니니쌤 오늘도 알차고 재밌었죠.
네.
자 다음 강의도 보도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.
보시고 싶으시면 우리 광고주님들이 광고를.
자 다음 선생님께 경례.
감사합니다.
백지훈 씨.
네.
제가 하나 좋은 거 알려드릴게요.
삼성전자 오늘 종가가 얼마야.
삼성전자의 오늘 종가는 281,000원입니다.
최근 법원 판결 소식으로 상승세를 보이며 마감되었네요.
오늘 삼성전자 그 노사 합의 결과 아직 안 나왔어.
오늘 진행된 삼성전자의 재협상에서는 아직 최종 합의에 이르지 못한 것으로 나타났습니다.
평소 이렇게.
잘 봐 백윤아.
두산 애너빌리티 오늘 몇 프로 올랐어.
두산 애너빌리티의 오늘 주가센트 상승세를.
자 이 뉴스 요약해줘.
이 뉴스는 소득 하위 70%에 해당하는 분들을 대상으로.
소득 하위 70%가 얼마야 월에.
기사에 나온 소득 하위 70%는 단순한 월 소득보다는.
금요가 13만 원 이하 4인 가구는 32만 원 이하일 때 대상이 됩니다.
세상 좋아졌지요.
이렇게 시간을 아끼는 겁니다.
요즘에 이렇게 좋은 게 나왔어요.